des choix dont matin on va pas fort
n'arrivera pas un alors il ya un sujet
en tous les cas qu'il ne vous cachera
pas c'est la guerre d'irak parce que je
crois que l'on a des positions assez
assez proches tous les deux j'ai lu
quand même d'un dans la presse
quotidienne régionale cette semaine des
déclarations que vous avez faites au
sujet de la guerre d'irak en disant
c'est un numéro de clown tragique et
planétaire oui quant à moi j'ai veillé
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin pour regarder
bush au moment où les hostilités
commençaient à la télévision il a l'air
vraiment d'un petit chimpanzé avec des
avec des yeux pétillants d'une
intelligence
à la mairie j'adore la mer je connais
mieux une certaine amérique que bush
sûrement il n'a pas lu un bouquin c'est
sûr il n'a pas lu john fante et il n'a
pas vu les films des films de kassav
être dit allen et il a il a pas de
guerre chouine il croit que c'est une
marque de jeans
donc c'est terrible parce que c'est en
plus c'est un gangster il est entouré de
gangsters ils veulent le pétrole pas
pour l'amérique ils le veulent pour eux
et je suis pas pour ça le meilleur ami
de cet abus s'est dit pouvoir faire un
chiche kebab
j'aurais été content mais vous avez
déclaré je le décrirais byblos et la
première guerre l'euthanasie qu on veut
du bien aux irakiens alors on les tue et
oui voilà on va pas dire autre chose
mais c'est quoi cette guerre s'est loupé
de toute façon parce que maintenant
c'est le bordel absolue et les hôpitaux
sont envahi il on peut même plus opérer
les gens il n'ya qu'un monument qui est
gardée c'est le ministère du pétrole
samedi tous je veux dire c'est
extravaganza d'histoire il faudrait
fermer sa gueule
moi je trouve très mais maintenant
formidable que chirac est ouvert sa
gueule
sauf que l'âge il me semble que
d'ailleurs depuis il a enfilé le
uniforme du général de gaulle et j'ai
peur qu'ils perturbent en talons
bien alors vous avez déclaré
vous avez déclaré du bonus pour conclure
dans cet article de l'est républicain
c'est une guerre pas schiste c'est un
propos de repas oui en privé on risque
de déplaire à quelques intellectuels qui
sont atteints de syncope intellectuelle
quand ils écrivent des articles dans le
monde
c'est pour ça que je fais du spectacle
moi j'avais vu un article dans le monde
récemment
récemment s'est vu quelques temps oui
signé c'est pas pour dénoncer je suis
pas une balance mais outre m
robin ses films voici l'homme